[Music]
they no longer have any military
opposition but they face what's possibly
an even bigger challenge
actually running the country and
creating a viable economy according to
the world bank 40 percent of
afghanistan's gdp was international aid
and once the taliban seized power much
of that aid was frozen the country is
facing economic collapse banks have
closed people are running out of food
the taliban is making overtures the
foreign minister recently hosted a
meeting of ambassadors in kabul the un
special representative to afghanistan
canadian deborah lyons was there
so what are the next steps
we get some insight from omar samad
afghanistan's ambassador to ottawa from
2004-2009
i know that you
witnessed the
decades of turbulence in afghanistan
that you know of course the history of
foreigners attempting to conquer the
country in that arc of history where do
you think afghanistan is right now
i hope afghanistan
finds its space its place
in the region in the world
we all hoped for the past 20 years that
it it did that it has after the 9 11
intervention took place
and i as an afghan who went back to try
to
reshape
and rebuild the new country
i was
hoping that
we would be back on our own feet
that we would own our own country that
we would rule according to the wishes of
our people
is it possible that the taliban of 2021
are different than the taliban of the
1990s they are more sophisticated in
some ways they can be
more dangerous
and but i also think they've learned
some lessons they're a bit more worldly
uh they have been exposed to the world
much more than they used to
uh they have seen how uh
you know how governments function
how people live their lives in other
countries even islamic especially
islamic societies they are in my opinion
being tested right now the burden of
proof is on the taliban and so
the question is how does the rest of the
world respond now
right
do you do you think
it is right and appropriate for
countries to consider
recognizing the taliban as the
government i think that
in some ways it's simple
if they show that they're broad-based
meaning they're accepting of other
political and social elements in society
to be part of a new order
if they respect men and women's rights
in afghanistan and allow women and girls
have to have access to education and
employment
if they allow a certain level of
freedoms such as media freedom which
actually still exists they haven't
cracked down totally on that
people still get on tv and criticize
them
which is amazing in some ways but
if they continue that
and if they crack down on international
organizations or terrorist groups that
are using afghanistan or want to use
afghanistan whether they're pro
tolerable or anti-talib and crack down
on those elements
whether they're anti-western or whether
they're anti-china or iran or russia
then i think that they will there's very
little room for the rest of the world
not to recognize them but those are some
really big conditions that they have to
meet well yes those are a lot of
conditions those are a lot of ifs
do you see any signs of those kinds of
advancements actually taking place
yes and no so you see
some girls going to school others not
you see boys going to school but then
women teachers not going to work or
women in general selectively go to work
but in general they don't and i think
the more presence
you have in afghanistan if the
international community is engaged if
the international media is still engaged
if there are some u.n agencies
functioning we would have a window into
afghanistan and we would know what the
taliban are doing and whether they're
changing or not if you shut down and you
close the country and you isolate the
country and you cut its lifelines then
obviously uh not only are we
jeopardizing their livelihoods and the
lives of afghans but we are also in some
ways
closing the door and basically saying
you can do whatever you want
and we're not watching and we're not
listening which is exactly what we did
in the 1990s which was in my in my view
a very big mistake
what role do you think countries like
canada
should play now what leverage does
canada have in changing the
circumstances on the ground improving
the circumstances on the ground for
people in afghanistan canada right now
is playing a very important role by
being a host country for thousands of
afghans who are leaving that is the part
of the generosity of canadians
but canada also has a lot to offer in
terms of humanitarian assistance because
that is a vital need right now we should
not forget the 35 million afghans for
whom we went and we claimed to have
fought for
and defended their rights canada also
should play a role in making sure that
the world is safe and that we all
are collaborating in the fight against
terrorism and that make sure that the
taliban played their role
canada eventually can play a major role
in sectors such as mining
and agriculture
and
industry in the future in afghanistan
i'm hoping i really hope that one day we
reached a point where we have canadian
investment and canadian expertise in
afghanistan again you're not totally
pessimistic is what i'm hearing no i'm
not i cannot i can't afford to be
totally pessimistic why is that why do
you feel you can't afford to be
pessimistic about the future because
that will take the country in in
in a very
bad and wrong
direction is that coming from your heart
as as an afghan well partly from my
heart but also partly from you know from
a policy perspective and and partly as a
diplomat
my job has been to
identify and resolve issues and problems
my job is not to make it more difficult
so we have a problem
my job is to to find solutions for it
and i know that
you know this it's too raw for now it's
really
everything is very raw for for the
moment and everybody is either very
upset and angry
or they are very disappointed
and vindictive
and i think that
we need to find a balance between
what
is very could be very detrimental to
afghanistan versus what can help us get
out of this mess
and and
back on track